welcome to your round seven recap of the  2014 us chess championships well a new  leader has emerged grandmaster Verona  cobian defeated ray Robson in a display  of power chess I really like the way I  played today I thought it was just equal  position rapin everything accurately and  I took advantage of it and a new leader  has risen to the top in the women's  championship as well international  master ana certain ski winning a  marathon game against Camilla begin sky  tea after a hundred moves she played the  move knight to e7 and her opponent  conceded defeat after King to the eighth  rook to be eight would be checkmate I'm  very happy being not a half point ahead  and leading but I'm still showed to face  my main rival arena in round 8 be sure  to join us for more exciting action as  we head into the final rounds of the  2014 us Chess Championships here in st.  Louis at one p.m. Central at us chess  chance calm